for rolling on what drug i've never done
molly isn't that wild me neither really
i have yeah no i have no i used to have
a desire to do molly but now i don't i'm
on other drugs which
ones
oh we were talking about like the plant
medicine stuff like the doing the
ceremonial like the psilocybin and
yeah so i'm not talking is that like
mushrooms mushrooms yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's like the technical term if you
don't know already we're talking to
candace thompson
nosy neighbors podcast brilliant
comedian um really quick uh before we
dive into uh plant medicine
all kinds of medicines drugs vitamins
supplements ancestral trauma uh
and um my panties are getting wet and
conspiracy theories let's just do a
proper intro for you and also some
context i always ask everyone on the
podcast i've been waiting to have you
for so long i want to wait till we have
the new studio yeah yeah so i'm kind of
geeking out that you're here but uh i am
uh very um pins and needles about to ask
are we friends
are we friends yes i always
ask the guests are we friends and i let
the guest answer so that you know when
you go to podcast and someone's like
this is my best friend candace thompson
and you're like
no and then now you're in this weird lie
that you didn't sign up for of course
and it's awkward and of course you don't
know where the person's from or what
their wife's name is yet you're their
best it's just it's and then you're
trapped in a fakery
uh like
well yeah but then and i think that we
don't give the audience enough credit
because they know they'll know within
three minutes whether or not why am i
watching youtube pretend that you're
friends this is embarrassing exactly um
so no to answer your question i would
say that we have gotten definitely
gotten closer through the pandemic
would i say you're a friend that i use
that term very very i'm very particular
with that word
i i probably would say that i only have
maybe
eight friends
people that i know would
let a ride or die would take a bullet
for me if i call them at three o'clock
in the morning because i need to go to
the hospital they would take me so what
i would say is
i wouldn't call you a friend but you're
someone that i
care about and i'm loving getting to
know you and i've been wanting to have
this conversation like an intimate
conversation with you because you and i
one on one have never really sat down
and done this so by the end of this
podcast i would like to say that we will
be friends full-on friends like i can
depend on whitney for some shit like if
some shit goes down and also and vice
versa and also we've we've kind of
circled each other in a way like as
comedians and i have definitely been
intimidated by you for a long time what
i know this is so stupid it's it's i
know what but like the comedy store like
like candace thompson is real deal
mafia comedy store
you know what i mean like
like
like people look at the ground when she
walks through the hallway
no but you're one of the ones that did
it the hard way um put in the work put
in the 10 000 hours and
um
you know when
shit hits the fan in terms of you know
stuff happening in comedy uh
negative
consequences or
an earthquake comes for the comedy store
it's like there's like four or five of
us that you go to like the the the coven
the godmothers of the comedy store and
you're one of them holding space just
holding space there and that's that you
know that's that's a lot it's like
because that space there's a lot of
negative energy and just comedy in this
industry and comedy in general also so
but to say that and say first thank you
like i just mean like if there's a
documentary on the comedy store in 50
years like you'll be one of the you know
10 people well they did a documentary
and they did not ask me
[Music]
they already did a documentary wasn't it
on show time
yeah
yeah no i'm like okay
there were people there who definitely
should have been there before me right
even though i wasn't even on this one
like who should have been a part of that
that weren't right and i was just like
well who did this who picked this yes
everything we see every documentary we
watch you know it's is going to be
through the lens of the person that's
making its contact list and what they
experienced and and how they want to
tell it you know so just to sort of set
the table for what we're about to talk
about and why i'm so excited about this
and the hardest thing about this this
interview this is gonna be an
embarrassment of riches and i just need
to go there will be a part two with
candace there will be a part two we're
not gonna get to everything today
because i don't want to get to i don't
want to uh throw down on stuff with a
little bit of everything superficially i
want to go like deep in like four or
five things instead of like hitting tiny
things yes but my addict yes brain just
wants to like do it all talk because
talking to you is like such a drug for
me
and so something with candace thompson
just in general is a let's question
everything person but but
but elegantly intelligently
classically and not sloppily so i'm so
excited to dive into like some like
let's question everything everything and
what is like right now for you
as a comedian as a woman
as a uh
not white woman what do we say now what
can i say you can we have never had a
problem with black
let me clear this up for every white
person listening
we actually i mean i don't know any
black person that refers to themselves
as african-american you only hear other
people non-black people saying it so
it's not really for us i don't know who
came up with that term
that's something for me to investigate
later in my conspiracies
but yeah no i don't know any black
person that has a problem being called
black well i remember the first time
that i got uh confronted when i called
someone african-american
and
they were like well i was born here i
mean i wasn't born in africa and i was
like
yeah yes okay
yes so what a way
like just like you know when your heart
takes a shit in your stomach and you're
just like i'm
what can you say it's just like but it's
again that wasn't like that's not out of
malice you just you just didn't know it
was out of ignorance not and but not and
i don't i'm not saying it's internalized
right it's just like i just didn't know
and i appreciate you correcting me so
now i know yeah you have food in your
teeth like help me tell you no i had
a little thing on my nose the other day
went and did a show
i'm out here
i had two shows i'm talking to i was
just doing supernovas i was talking to
comments i'm talking about people in the
crowd
i get home and it's just dot it looked
like it looked like i had like a pimple
and i scratched it so it was blood it
was like blood
on the stigmata yeah
just blinking from the face
your
[Laughter]
[Music]
we're joking guys we're it's a joke
we're not going to talk about vaccines
here this is a comedian's joke this is
how we joke but yeah continue i don't
even remember what we're talking about
oh someone corrected you you okay blood
on your nose there was blood on my nose
oh we were talking about yes someone
just i appreciate the people that come
forward and say that take that
uncomfortable moment and be like i'm
going to help you even though this is
what's going to happen right now is
going to embarrass you a little bit but
i'm helping you i got traumatized
because i had a booger hanging from my
nose when i was a kid and my best friend
my best friend
did not tell me we were in the we were
in like jamaica
and
we were in under the water i came up
there's a long like a snotty booger
snotty
slug coming out of my right nostril i'm
talking to my best friend deshawn i hope
she's going to watch this i'm talking to
her her boyfriend
his friend were in this water
talking like 30 minutes and i walk away
in there and then i i was like
what is this
the booger and she didn't tell me she
ain't telling me i was like you're
supposed to be my best so ever since
then was she at the time
i said kids but we were probably like
fresh out of college do you think she
knew
and didn't tell you on purpose because
you're so pretty stop it she's also very
pretty
she's also very pretty i don't think you
know the most insecure people on the
planet are yes pretty girls this is true
this is true i don't think it came from
that i asked her i said why did you not
she didn't embarrass you she said i just
don't do that
by the way i used to be that person i
would walk if someone had something in
their teeth i'm like i don't want to
embarrass them but if you don't tell
them they're even more embarrassed you
don't know where they're going job
interview you just got to look at the
motives i think for me it's like what
was the motive was the motive i don't
embarrass you was the motive i'm doing
this on purpose maliciously to sabotage
you i don't think it was calculated like
that no but my
my shit and everyone here knows it is
thank me later that's my brand you're
not gonna like me right now but you'll
thank me later me later anyway so
so we're both that those type of people
yeah yeah and i do think that my
um
i did have done a couple
of medicines
when my dad died when my dad died i did
ayahuasca
and
when
over the pandemic i microdosed on ls uh
mushrooms but i think i metabolized it
too quick what oh yeah what's going on
with you you did text you are in some
flow yeah i'm in a i'm in a weird i'm
not even on this plane i'm not like this
i'm in a space right now where it's
i have one foot out of this industry
because i'm so
just
none of this matters none of this
matters that's where my head is right
now so i did and is that it just
elaborate is it because we're all dying
is it
uh terror management theory
it's just
the only thing that really matters is
that we're
taking care of ourselves and enjoying
our time here and and loving and helping
others like that's all that matters and
what was the the impetus
for
this like
the the beginning of this journey okay
so
i've always been like a weirdo i've
always felt different i've always felt
like i'm just not from here i've always
felt that like i'm just a person who's
just going through the motions but i
don't really fit in anywhere i've always
felt that
even in my family i didn't feel like i
felt fit in and then can i just guess
more about that yeah i'm sorry i'm just
it's about elaborate like did was it
like when you're talking to someone do
you feel like you're
pretending or like looking down on
yourself or disassociating yes i've
always felt like
i can never fully be present someplace
because i don't fully
understand
how am i going to articulate this
like i feel like i'm
behaving a certain way because i've been
conditioned to behave a certain way like
a robot zombie yeah but that's not who i
am
so in just conversations i've always
felt a little bit of awkwardness with
people because
i am like
pretending to be human if that makes
sense yeah well we're all we all are
we're all animals there's no such thing
as humans spirits we're like yeah like
we all chose to come here to have this
experience but none of us are like from
here we don't know and and we're just
doing for the most part behaving the way
we were taught to behave but you're also
operating on data that you know is
um bogus
100 like you're operating like we're go
we're doing all these like uh
these socially conditioned movements and
we're all just going to work a good job
we're all just full of shit we're
punching we're just like monkeys in a
lab absolutely go i went to college
would i have gone to college now if
knowing what i know now no i would not
have wasted that time i would not have
wasted my parents money and put it
towards something that's more tangible
like a house like i tell my parents when
i saw them in
over christmas um i was just like you
guys sent me to college why didn't you
buy me a house like put that money
i could have property right now i mean
because i'm not using my degree at all
because our the our primary caretakers
were like
look we need to play in this rigged game
absolutely so that you'll win you know
absolutely and we can't the best thing
we can do for our children at the time
was to help
is going to college this is going to get
you ahead financially yeah and we're
going to play this we know it's rigged
we know it's bogus see but they my
parents absolutely didn't know it's
rigged my parents
are fully in like fully in this matrix
like fully like
plugged in and can't there's nothing i
can say to them in this lifetime that i
don't think that's gonna wake them up or
change their minds about um they're just
here they're just they're great parents
but they didn't teach me like oh there's
so much more this like candice like
you're we're all energy like they didn't
tell me any of that it's just not in
their realm of i told my mom that i did
combo which is
what i was texting about briefly just to
explain what it was but i showed her
like the little i've got
the points on my
community okay this is gonna end up on
wiki feet
oh yeah what's your score i don't know i
don't look i don't even know if i'm on
there
cover up my toes because
can you see okay yes so explain yes
combo uh and i told my mom saw those on
my my leg was like what's that candace
what did you do like immediately what
did you what is with it on your body and
i told her i was like i did combo and
she's like what's that and i was like
well it's a it's a detox down to your
ancestral dna it's literally
uh it's frog medicine from the amazon
that you have a medicine person or
shaman administer to you and you just
start purging so
in kind of like ayahuasca like you'll
purge but
purge
everything like people think puking they
think shitting they think
i'm a
yeah apparently so emotional
the first thing i did when the shaman
administered the combo on my point the
combo's different than ayahuasca yeah
they're two totally they're two
different i haven't done aya yet but i'm
that's next on my journey i'm going to
do that next but yeah no this is this is
different
and i feel i i i can't compare because
i've never done aya but when i when she
first administered that on me i my first
purge was crying i cried for like two
minutes straight just bawl not just
i bawled yeah like
yeah yeah
it's it's your your it's that ugly cry
it's like you have nine chins yes yeah
and you pop you have to pop a blood
vessel i mean i didn't cry till i was
like 32 for the first time in your life
i mean truly
this was definitely that for me when i
did combo and i do want to give a shout
out to my friend davina who is the one
that
introduced me to combo
i saw the little dots the points on her
ankle and i was like what is that
and she told me and i was like
immediately she was like it's a detox
down to your ancestral dna and i was
like
go on
sold where do i sign up
and she referred me to this woman um
named michelle mckay who's a
full-on like witch like full-on medicine
woman like full-on her instagram is
priestess of the wild she's amazing
she's like a healer her mission princess
priestess
priestess of the wild her mission is to
heal every woman in the world because i
am princess
i was about to sue her i was about to
sue her because i
trade mark's ass to her she is
definitely a witch
if you want all of your hair to fall out
then i recommend you sue her which by
the way my um therapist also is uh which
um
well which is but i remember we all are
we go into um this uh
you know hold on before we do that can
we finish hearing about combo yeah
you're right okay
so anyway so yeah so i'm doing this
experience i'm purging
emotionally first then came the vomit
and they give us and this is in front of
people right like because you know i
think i most people do i in front of
other people as well so it's like me and
i think there was like four other people
who were doing combo with me that day
and so
they told us before like you guys no
one's gonna be focused on anything
you're doing because everyone's going to
be so focused on themselves because
you're just going to be you're going to
feel like there's like your body your
food poisoning like you're going to feel
like you're sick and that's all you're
going to worry about so don't worry
about it this person's farting next to
you or if you have to fart or if you
have to burp no one cares can we just
define is it combination therapy no no
no combo k-a-m-b-o
so it's named after the chief of a tribe
from the amazon i don't know how many
centuries ago tom
this is jeff bezos thing what i'm joking
i was like what time did jeff bezos i'm
sure amazon.com has bought
i was like what are you talking about
let's just uh when you're living with a
mental illness like depression or
addiction there are times you may think
you would try anything combo
uh
maybe uh it's uh maybe you know this
involves frogs and some ceremony but
you're a little fuzzy on the rest of the
details
in a nutshell it's it's kind of like
frog mucus the bright green giant monkey
frogs that live in the amazon secrete a
poisonous waxy substance to defend
themselves from predators that is what
is used in combo ceremony research has
shown that substance that that substance
is loaded with all kinds of powerful
biopeptides peptides and enzymes one of
the peptides interacts with the body's
own opiate receptors so it can help pain
the ceremony itself may also create a
calming effect it's
it's amazing and
it's uh it'll happen very quickly if
you've got a good shaman good medicine
person that you're working with um it'll
happen you'll be done your whole combo
purging experience will be done in like
a half hour like how do you take how do
you ingest it
okay so this is the this is the
wild i mean it's all wild it's all wild
yeah we are here we are
we're past
if
if if y'all are listening anyone who's
listening is fucking in there
and know that if you are still watching
this and then you're being called you're
being you might be being called to combo
oh i'm just saying
i'm just saying so
they take a like a stick looks like a
twig kind of it's just wood and then she
lights it on fire at one end of it then
blows out so it's kind of like a
cigarette butt and then they s like
really quickly onto your skin oh without
what the dots are yeah that's what the
points are yes
and then what if that's the only way i
can come
well then that's a you're not a problem
you're killing two birds with one stone
you're getting rid of your ancestors
[Laughter]
so yeah so they'll do points that's what
the little dots are called they're
called points on you and so
the more points they give you the more
potent the medicine is going to be so if
it's like your first time doing it
whoever you see might only give you like
let's say four or five points on those
just burns um i did seven and you're the
medicine people are just obviously very
intuitive so they can tell kind of what
you can handle like what their strength
is whatever so she gave me seven
and uh
it worked like i was
most people like are you sure you're
gonna purge if you're with the right
person you will purge like this woman
has never worked with someone and they
didn't purge and that's because she
knows how how to apply the medicine and
how to use it so
i was purging within everyone was
purging within like four physically or
emotionally emotionally and physically
the first time i did it i did it three
times in one month i did it three times
in september and that's what's
recommended
there is just like where does one find a
shaman that does this
on uh craigslist that's what
why did that go on craigslist yeah no i
like i've got my referral from my friend
davina joy uh she is amazing another
goddess she like was like i saw i saw
her ankle and she told me she was like
i'm doing combo and i was like what is
combo because the one thing that where i
go and i was with a friend of mine
stephanie sabara yesterday who um
used to do the podcast uh so retrograde
and
and i'm just stopping to say that like
we've seen a lot of these people that
are like the bikram yoga guy the wild
wild country
wild wild country
yeah
so there's a lot of the the the equine
therapist at miraval the guy that guy
wyatt whatever like a lot of these
people
are toxic yeah and
so for me it's also like just
do your homework on the person that is
because you're in a very vulnerable
situation oh for sure and a lot of uh
people prey on
people that are teachable and just want
to get better and
will sign up to be inebriated in order
to heal their old wounds for sure so
it's like i know a lot of people
that run rehabs who took advantage of
the
people going through rehab you know and
so
that's that's just like a tricky part of
this like wellness community it's a
tricky part of every community like any
community like even just going to your
like that you know yourself community we
call it 13 stepping like if you're
trying to sponsor the cute new young
girl that comes in you know or the cute
guy that comes in it's i mean it's in
comedy you know it's like
we know this what women that have
gathered you are a conspiracy therapist
it's the wildest thing you've said since
you sat down candace so what i'll say is
like it's on us to go
okay i want to do frog therapy but like
you know go
once research the person that is taking
you through this absolutely and
and talk to people that have done it
that's the way i i trusted davina i
trusted her 100 i trust anyone named i
mean if she's got the name as divine so
it's like she knows what she's talking
about but she's such a happy be careful
because within this within there's a lot
of people that will
take advantage i'm not trying to be
paranoid i just
no do your research do your research 100
i just happen to trust the person that i
got my information from my referral
friend do you do it alone or do you have
someone come bring someone you trust
with you
and if your gut says this is weird just
go can we reschedule your gut
is 100
and for women it's actually our womb
that's one of our things that um the
medicine woman was teaching she's so
about empowering women but that that's
another like
psyop is telling women that that's your
gut that's talking to you it's our womb
we literally have the universe inside of
us we have a portal to the universe
inside of us so
when that's talking you need to listen
we bring people here
i interrupt my womb when it's talking
you're like excuse me i'm
[Music]
you're talking too much and you're
second on the call sheet but the gift of
fear gavin tobacco i'm holding it up
right now um always like it's because to
me i'm i'm like on some like
right now
because we can go to doctors and finally
we could all like if you could finally
at a point where you can get health care
all this covert stuff it's like i'm at
the point where i'm like
does that feel true exactly like i like
i'll read an article exactly because
like it's so hard to corroborate
anything that you read on any news site
these days it's like i
this doesn't feel true i have to like
check do a gut check yes
that's all that's all you have to do is
listen to yourself and that's what's i
always do that and i've always marched
through a beat of my like a different
drummer because i've always just
listened to myself like that's god
talking to me right like that's all i
and god by the way just in 12-step
programs in anything like god is a word
that i like this like feminism or genius
or it's lost its value and it's you know
i think especially given like what's
happened in the catholic church no
god is a tough word like i don't believe
in god it's like you you thought the
universe called whatever you wanted yeah
call it your god can be a canoe and
could i had a sponsee where their um god
or higher power
higher power was dance
it's all in order to believe in god the
universe something big all you have to
believe is that you're not god
you're not god but you you're not god
but you have god is in all of us
if that makes sense whatever that word
mean and i say dog god dog is god
backwards source whatever you want to
call it is the creator whatever that's
that is what i live by and that's what
has taken me
and made me who i am and this has gotten
me this far i'm not happy whatever it
can be a rock
it could be the rock
whatever you need if you want to worship
dwayne johnson
that's on you
we are now taking a break from whitney
and our guest and our we have another
special guest here giannis pappas is
here yes you brought me in for this
particular ad read because i'm the only
dude here yeah you like dude i'm a
fucking guy yeah
um so manscaped we've talked about
manscaped a lot
you need to shave your balls there's no
it's it's if you don't shave your balls
anymore we're all going to start growing
out our pit hair like where if if you
don't like
like it's fine but we stop shaving our
legs and stop shaving our armpits i
don't think you want that so let's all
just shave and and it's not a every
couple days i shave because then you're
going to have stubble
so so this razor can i tell you this is
the best uh thing i can possibly say
about this we couldn't find the
manscaped razor because alex alex my guy
had already opened it was using it
remember when i cleaned out the room
last night that's used
well he's i don't think he has any hair
in his body right i think he's naturally
hairless there's a little on here he has
some on his back lower
hand like and then on his tushy but i
kind of like that and in addition to
that razor giannis is so excited to
announce manscape's brand new ultra
premium collection believe it or not
they're moving above the bikini line
this is an all-in-one skin and hair care
kit for the everyday man that covers him
from head to toe enhance his perfect
grooming routine with our ultra premium
collection this package includes
manscaped premium deodorant i do use
this hydrating body shampoo body wash
two-in-one shampoo and conditioner plus
a free skiff of a three pack set of lip
balm that is what dudes wow that is what
dudes need yeah get 20 off and free
shipping with the code whitney at
manscape.com that's 20 percent off
and free shipping with your code we go
is happening guys the only smell you'll
want on him yeah i just don't know if me
and patrick should leave i don't know
what we're doing i don't know thanks
thanks to manscape
[Music]
giannis did you know that an estimated
five billion plastic hand soap and
cleaning bottles are thrown away every
year i did know that and it it keeps me
up at night
i can't sleep
enter oh no your wife would know you
know nothing about cleaning at all enter
blue land blue land's idea is simple and
beautiful buy the bottle once refill it
forever no more plastic waste the only
thing you need is to discard your
outdated idea that eco-friendly products
are more expensive and less effective
that's true so blue land here's what i'm
gonna say about blue land i feel like
when you're buying these toxic cleaners
you're just contributing to like
you know this night this toxic nightmare
cesspool we live in because look when
your children grow up i don't want them
swimming in a fucking chemical
ocean
right right right yeah give me a child
okay good i mean my eggs are available i
mean i'll give you one too i was
listening to natasha legero
and moshe cash's podcast endless
honeymoon and they were talking about
blue land and i was so jealous i was
like how come we don't have blue ants
for our sponsors i was like this is like
i was annoyed but i went on and i
ordered some of it
i was just like a customer in that
moment and it was just so ironic because
i was in like appalachia tennessee where
all these people have been poisoned for
so long and i was just like cause it was
like because here's what you do you hear
an ad for something like you're like
i'll get to it i'll get you're like i'll
wait for it so i was like just get on
bitch your phone right now and get it
and then also this packaging is amazing
because yes i'm sick of my house looking
like a fucking
shitty pharmacy you just fill blue lands
beautiful instagramable bottles with
warm water pop in one of the hand soap
or spray cleaner tablets and within
minutes you have powerful cleaning
products in the most incredible sense
such as iris agave purine lemon and
lavender eucalyptus right now you can
get 20 off your first order when you go
to blueland.com
whitney so here it is yep that's 20 off
your first order of any blueland
products at blueland.com whitney
blueland.com that's whitney
february 10th we're in cincinnati oh hi
y'all we're at the this weekend what is
taft theater it's that's after taft
barnard taft fat fat presence right taft
theater this week and february 11th i am
ben bethel bethlehem because i'm baby
jesus february 12th montclair new jersey
we love you come come all come that's
where dory's from montclair oh no yeah
yeah my best friend dory um walmart
theater this weekend that's not this
weekend yes it is it's this weekend i'm
in new jersey this weekend yep when this
airs this week oh
right she's gonna show up look at my
fucking website no my robot will be
there with emily it's fine but also it
always works out oh we're all gonna die
one day who cares by the way i'm sorry
the last two years every date has been
rescheduled 15 times so there's no way i
don't yeah i mean
february 18th will be in omaha
we're going to put the
in omaha
the performing arts center uh february
19th we'll be in kansas city missouri
kansas city chiefs baby
hyena hyenas we're not gonna call them
the chiefs uh and we're gonna pay the
cheerleaders but that's a later thing
i'm gonna try to go to the super bowl in
life um back to our guest
so frog therapy you're doing it
so yeah so that's the uh i did the um i
did the emotionally purge the first time
i did emotionally purge first crying and
then i did the vibe what are you
thinking about while you're crying that
the only thing that i was thinking about
because i didn't know have a clue where
it was coming from i just knew that i
was bawling and that's i kept thinking
to myself
what is this this old pain that you're
carrying and
i knew it was that because it had to be
that but i didn't know where
specifically like i couldn't i wasn't
like getting visions of like oh this was
like an ancestor from blah blah blah
blah blah i wasn't getting i was i just
had question marks but i knew that it
was something a release because i'm not
a crier either i'm not like i wasn't i
don't think i was bad as you where i
went and didn't cry to my 30s right but
i was not i'm not a crier i'm just not i
would cry like like randomly like
because i had in my 20s um like an
intrigue addiction like uh love
addiction is is kind of a and you know
all these words words are just imperfect
and we're gonna have to deal with it
like in 20 years everything we're saying
is going to be offensive um but you know
when you go into sex love uh
addiction uh recovery
um
there's something called intrigue which
is kind of like what people do now with
parasocial relationships with famous
people intrigue is like you're kind of
in a relationship with somebody
uh that doesn't know you're in a
relationship with them and it's like
kind of just an obsession to avoid
intimacy and avoid being in a real
relationship so it's it's a co-worker
it's a celebrity it's the person at you
know
your local starbucks and you're in kind
of this
it's like a
yeah which is uh it's also like a form
of sexual anorexia like if you had
sexual trauma as a child and you kind of
are like it's it's an ability to be in a
fake relationship uh to avoid intimacy
and to stay emotionally immature and
unharmed physically and to get out of
being sexual um
and
yeah we just got to get you off farmers
only um
i know you want to live off
poison only
this is where i am now only if you
only
have wounds on you ken
from frog therapy are we gonna get along
tender.com
dying to know the rest of the okay so i
know i'm sorry
no but like we're coming and going back
but it's like there's certain things
that i just like to if the someone
listening or watching has a question to
be able to go like okay let's elaborate
on that and then come back and this will
be finished for sure okay so
um
so yeah so
the
the first time was emotional
and then the vomiting and then the butt
purging
not and not everybody's gonna butt purge
and i wish i wasn't a button also if you
want to just put purge anytime you want
to a lapels
wait what pills aloe oh aloe vera pills
is the brand i use if you're just like
been traveling a lot altitude and you're
just not able to excrete the way you
want to be exciting
take one aloe pill
but
the next day needs to be pretty flexible
day yeah don't don't do it on it for the
night before a road trip or like no
you need to be buy it or like coachella
yeah just do it on a saturday night for
a sunday you got to be near yeah
you're going to be yeah you're going to
be doing a poo poo like every hour senna
too send a leaf you'll lose like four
pounds oh easy easy um
yeah and
apparently and not everyone is a butt
percher
i knew going in that i was a butt purger
because i've done
other like cleanses and detoxes where
that's where what your diet really quick
just decide is there something you have
to prepare diet wise in your diet in
general is you should i
before you do combo it's recommended
that you eat pretty clean beforehand eat
don't fast though don't fast you want to
have stuff in your clean which means no
no fried foods and clean can be a
different different it could mean
different things so
some people think you have to give up
meat to be eating clean that's not true
you can have clean meat right there's a
way to get like clean meat so just
because someone says they're eating
clean doesn't necessarily mean they're
vegan or that they're plant-based or
just vegetarian whatever and forget the
preservatives if it's frozen for sure
for sure and i know plenty of people who
are vegan and vegetarian who eat trash
like who are not that's not clean yes
yes yes like people that do yoga aren't
always
sane exactly exactly or calm yeah it's
just that you've been in the whole foods
parking lot recently
fucking bat shit crazy people when i see
someone hearing yoga mad i'm like like
triggered so so you were eating clean
anyway i owe it yeah no i'm uh uh i'm
like annoying with how i know i remember
we were there one time when i was like
my friends call me the ruiner like i had
like real battle like we were in a
writer's room not too long ago and
he has a song candace ruins everything
because i do like you bring everyone was
bringing their lunch out and i'm like
cancer cancer gmos
are you sure you want to do that
going up to crafty right and they're
coming back what's your cheeto type
yeah like no and i'll call it out like
and i again if this is from love yeah it
is it's not from a place of me wanting
to control you and i know as a woman
that's another thing we have to deal
with is like a lot of times when we talk
to people and men they're just like
you're not getting you're not you're not
you're perceiving it as that but not
trying to help yeah yeah um so yeah no
it comes from love i just want people to
like people don't even realize like how
terrible seed oils are for them seed
oils are awful like i went home and my
mom's like still cooking with canola oil
i'm like what are you doing also by the
way most olive oil is cut with canola
oil because of the uh italian mafia
exactly yeah mafia runs out
too and you shouldn't be um cooking with
olive oil because it's certain heats
it's carcinogenic exactly this is all
information that like no one has time to
get it all so when you get me
which is why it's our job to just share
the information because no one has time
to to get it all and we just have to be
the robin hood
of information like this so we can just
like spit it out
it's also like people i and i don't care
if you think i'm a naggy bitch i just
want to help you
and we don't have to be friends because
you only have eight friends right
exactly i don't need more i'm not taking
i'm not taking new applications at the
moment yeah anyway but i just want this
to get out there it's like with dogs
it's like everyone's like we feed our
dogs vegetables now and their dogs are
vegan it's like be beans peas and
lentils for your dogs that cause it will
give your dog heart disease that's not
good for us either by the way if you do
like lent this and again this is
something that i think a lot of vegans
and plant-based people do lentils it's a
great source of protein whatever unless
you cook them a certain way
they have chemicals in there that cause
inflammation inside of us
lectins i believe is what they're called
and so you need to like the pressure
cooker is one way to to make some make
those more and not innocuous uh but also
um
sprouting them so like if you were to
sprout your legumes that's a better way
but beans and lentils and all those
the way people traditionally cook them
they're not great for you they're not
great for you if you ingest so don't get
me started on arsenic and rice oh i know
rice tends to absorb uh brown rice too
yeah it has arsenic because we're like
oh brown rice is healthier yeah and then
the arsenic content of raw rice varies
from 0.1 to .4 milligrams of inorganic
arsenic uh but
here's what i'll say though let's i
don't know whatever to be like
when i started learning anything when i
started yeah learning all this i'm like
what can i eat but the worst thing for
you is that that that is the cortisol
that you're emitting stressing out over
what to eat oh so it's also not about
what you're eating it's about how you
feel about what you're eating as well
right so it's like if you're running
around the airport going i can't eat
anything i can't eat anything it's
better to just eat it from what i
understand
just eat the piece of sabara pizza and
don't emit the cortisol and the
adrenaline and the stress because that's
what's really gonna thin the lining of
your heart yeah don't worry about it
yeah just so carry on yes enjoy your
life and
the way you feel about it and also
everybody is a snowflake sorry yeah and
oh that's like was a word that was used
in i think the election or something
like everybody's body is so different
your hormones are different your
ancestral trauma is different your blood
type is different what you've evolved to
be able to digest is different i mean as
dr bo said this who um uh emily i don't
think you were with me when i went to
this uh guy because i just having like
my migraine journey i had to go to so
many doctors for so long and there was
this guy dr beau who was like a big like
hollywood like nutrition guy and it was
based on and my thing is take what you
like and leave the rest like yes get a
bunch of information
experiment see what works for you and
like talk to yourself and your inner
child and go okay this is what works for
me yes because no one is going to know
100 fully how to help you no you have
it's impossible it's an inside job so
take what you like leave the rest but i
remember um he did my blood type
and uh
and i was like well so if i'm traveling
if i'm in like an airport like should i
just eat a banana and he was like your
blood type a you eating you eating a
banana you might as well put a gun in
your mouth
because he also bitch
he also slept upside down and he was an
aquitarian and
he was like
yeah he was
he was just
like he only drank uh water and
yeah and he and i stopped going to him
because he was giving me a colonic and
he name dropped jessica alba while he
was
and things were i was watching the
things come out of my butt during the
colonic like
poop like that gerbil coming like i
don't even know what that is
like is that a gummy bear like i was
things were coming out and he was
name-dropping celebrities that he he's
like well when i was doing this to
albert i was like gotta go you can't
that means he's gonna be telling what
was coming out of you to whoever's in
there which i was like that's just a red
flag that yeah as someone that
consistently paints red flags
white
like right just gonna right
it's time to time to move on yeah um but
yeah no i've always been just obsessed
because you would ask like why what
brought me to this like doing the combo
and the health stuff and the spiritual
stuff but i've always been kind of just
like
into health and and becoming the best
version of myself and i even i mean i
went to college for dietetics that's
what my degree is in is in nutrition and
dietetics so
yeah do you feel like anything you
learned there like were you sitting
there going like that's not true yeah no
i didn't know it remember my food
pyramid 20 years ago was just beans
bread cheese
cheetos
and these are the people we're listening
to telling us what's best for us even
when you're being taught about nutrition
were you sitting in that class being
like i knew better can i this is what
this is what really got me curious about
health and nutrition was because
i grew up
we grew up around like at the same time
like we were growing up in the 90s right
of the country i was in uh cincinnati at
the time we had moved from new york to
cincinnati when i was like almost 10
years old but we were i was like i
remember in the 90s there was remember
the low fat craze remember snackwells
remember do you remember olestra
fat-free potatoes that was having you
run you think you talked about butt
purging it said on the it's that on the
back leakage it said it may uh prohibit
absorption of vitamin d and we were like
okay this sounds okay remember what was
that i would try it was warning anal
leakage like written on well i was
actually and i was also on
i was on accutane at the time so i had
anal bleeding from the accutane and
leakage from the
there was also sugar-free like snack
wells uh
uh and i remember them they were called
like um they were like you're eating a
yoga mat little pieces of yogurt yeah
like chocolate it was foam it was
disgusting it was actually like fun it
was disgusting yeah and so my whole
theory when everyone's like why do you
have such nice skin i'm like i think i'm
embalmed because i ate so many chemicals
that i've been preserved my instead of
sweat i
uh
formaldehyde
i'm made of teflon
i am a frying pan i've been frying pan
as faith yeah there was like diet there
was an ocean spray diet
uh drink that had zero calories crystal
light all that stuff it's just full of
artificial chemicals yeah so this is
where you know i grew up growing up
watching this stuff and i remember like
being so obsessed with fat being like i
can't that is bad we learn fat fat makes
fat which is not true not true at all
yeah exactly and i was
i was thicker when i was younger okay i
was thinking more fat free i ate the
heavier i was up because i would eat
like five boxes of snack bags exactly
because you're not getting fed
there's no nutrition it's all
superficial exactly nonsense i remember
being so obsessed because this is the
the world we live in like we're watching
looking at you know who's on tv and the
magazine covers and me having a
different kind of body being like i want
to look like that i remember going on
like um
uh i would go to over-the-counter was it
like dexa trim remember dexter that was
like speed wasn't that it was meth yes
it's meth
so okay so dexa trim was i would take i
took this too but you could get it like
like cvs the over-the-counter
over-the-counter dietary supplement
meant to assist with weight loss dexa
trim claims it gives you the power to
lose weight curb binges and keep you in
a in control of your diet current
dexagem products available
yeah so um i was like 14.
um
was it just caffeine and mess
i think it was green tea actually this
feels like some dr oz shit but um but
also i remember reading a book i'm sure
it's toxic now i can't like condone
endorse it but i remember it kind of
changed my life it was called skinny
bitch oh i remember that book
tough love guide for savvy girls who
want to stop eating crap and looking
fabulous like that sucks but it was like
instead of eating healthy 20 fat-free
cookies eat
a like a chunk of cheese
and half an avocado like eat fat like
because when i was had eating disorders
my hair was falling out i had like i
looked like theovan i had an accidental
mullet and you know i like voluntary i
was just gray like my teeth i never had
any energy but i was eating fat free and
my hair just looked like just french
fries coming out you know
it's like fat we our body especially
women especially women uh our hormones
we need fat we are supposed to have a
certain amount of body fat on us for
child bearing purposes yeah well not you
and me but
we're barren for um for touring purposes
for sitting on planes for five hours six
times a week for being able to hump a
stool at the comedy store opener and
closer yeah i need fat on my ass so that
i can uh hump the stool and not stay not
damaged
my uterus
um
but yeah we were so so misinformed so i
remember
being like i gotta stay away from fat
right so i would not eat anything that
had fat in it
and i would come home from school after
like not eating during the day because i
i didn't know what i was doing but i was
like i probably eat too much that's why
i probably need to lose some weight so i
would go the whole day without eating
come home and eat a bag of like a big
bag of like schneider's pretzels because
they were fat free right if they and by
the way i i they would you would chew
them for a long time they were hard they
would like cut the inside of your mouth
oh they were very aggressive i would
also do turkey jerky because i didn't
have a lot of money and it would last
you but you would like get the oral
fixation of dying on something yes just
like that i'd covered maple syrup but
that's another story wait what maple
syrup because you know the um the master
cleanse was like a vitamin and barrel
there's a vitamin and maple syrup that
it has a lot of vitamins actually it's
like it has a lot of minerals in there
as well yeah so it's like a grade b
maple syrup yeah so if i like put maple
syrup on the turkey jerky i would like
get the protein
and then quinoa and quinoa of course
which i i pronounced kanoa until like
until 44 years ago exactly
but yeah i just remember being so like
why am i gaining weight because i was
not eating much except this whole bag of
pretzels this is all i'm eating why am i
gaining weight and i remember talking to
a gym one of my gym teachers and being
like
telling him what i was doing and how i
was like no i can't he was like don't
you eat like peanut butter or like nut
butters or whatever and i was like no i
that's got a lot of fat in it so i've
just been doing like
i'll do like more jelly i'll do jelly on
something because that's got no fat in
it yeah he's like but it's all sugar he
just and he goes candace no you're doing
everything backwards that's got it's
loaded with sugar your body needs fat so
you should do and i remember being like
we've been lied to like everything
that's in the media is low fat low fat
low fat low fat and i just remember
being mad being like feel like
bamboozled so that was kind of what
the the main reason was for me going to
pursue dietetics in school because i was
like i want to learn how to
take care of myself and actually be
healthy and then
even going through school
and getting that degree
i'm now you know in my
30s and just being like i
am still getting sick
having that revelation being like why am
i still getting sick and like i'm
supposed to be a person who knows how to
not get sick and take care of them and
be healthy right i've got a degree in it
right that's everything is having a
degree
i just still didn't know i still didn't
know i didn't learn how to do all of
that stuff and take care of myself and
how to fix myself until i
in what year was 2018 when i just
crashed and burned like i got super sick
super sick to the point where i like
didn't couldn't like leave my house
because i was like what kind of sex like
i kept getting sinus infections um i
kept getting like i had an awful rash
awful rash over my like my face my neck
like to the point was like i can't leave
the house because this is embarrassing
and i just did a bunch of rea and i went
to doctor after doctor after doctor and
they're just like we don't know what
this is
take these antivirals we think it's
probably a virus take this and i'm like
well how are you prescribing something
that i'm supposed to say like it's pms
and ibs go home it's nothing you're fine
if you're a woman at that time doctors
are like it's probably just your period
you're probably like i think i don't
know
i i think i'm i know i i i know the
difference right i'm not well i'm
telling you i'm not asking you and so uh
yeah they kept just they were
prescribing like antivirals and i was
like but you don't even know what this
is
yet so why am i why are you telling me
to take something why are you
prescribing something this is in ohio no
this is here okay this is here i would
just be like are you jogging in the la
air
i mean which i was having migraines for
uh years when i first moved here of
course i was stressed out because i
didn't have any money and i was hustling
and trying to get on the coffee but i
was jogging outside in l.a and i finally
went to a doctor that was that was um uh
indian from india and he was like what
are you doing for exercise i'm like oh i
can't afford a gym membership so i just
jog outside every day and he's like you
cannot run you have to stop breathing
you have to stop breathing elliott
you're like smoking like four packs of
cigarettes yeah
it's because of the smog yeah that's
awful it's just and the tap water out
here i mean tap water in general but tap
water out here specifically is really
really really bad back when we had water
right um
but so let's go back to frogs
and what happened so you're purging
ancestral trauma and then i want to make
sure that we um loop in epigenetic
imprinting for sure for sure so yeah so
and all that to say like was this is my
journey leading up to why i got into all
the like the health the combo and the
ceremonial psilocybin is because i feel
like the health part of my journey was
like the first part of it like healing
myself which i did um through just
changing my diet and um i just went all
raw for a point of point in time where i
was just eating like raw fruits and
vegetables
and uh i got so much mucus out of my
body that was making me sick and
haven't been sick since and so i was
like oh i just am on to something now
and then so once i found out oh i i can
heal myself i think ever since then like
that seed was planted of like how far
can i take this like what else can i
heal
and so
just the universe just brought me to
again meeting uh running into my friend
davina and talking to her about combo
and that's what brought me to this
journey and just being like okay i did
the health part let's do the spiritual
part let's get to let's let's fully heal
yourself candace and so
uh
after all the the first time i did it
and all the purging you're supposed to
go back two more times in the in that in
that moon cycle so i went and did it
three times
i'm just
yeah yeah yeah yeah and that's that's
another that's another uh you know
euphemism for our periods you can say
moon cycles like yeah yeah so i i like i
like calling my moon cycle my moon cycle
just makes me feel more feminine
you know
yeah i mean it's just we have all these
awful terms for it that i'm just like
man we're supposed to honor what is it
flow like oh yeah on flow yeah there's
another one yeah it's just like my
period in so long do not you haven't
i'll have like a little like black tar
visitor once every color
i'll have like some skid marks like i
have like an oil spill every now and
then
like randomly one of the things that i
wanted to do when i went in with the
combo was i wanted to get more in touch
with my feminine side
and
i people like what are you talking about
i think you're feminine i'm like i am a
woman
but i wouldn't necessarily
describe me as feminine like i've been i
was a tomboy and i know that word is
like not pc anymore but fuck it i don't
care i don't care about political uncle
tomboy you cannot that is
uh but yeah no i grew up just you know
my sister for halloween would be a
princess and i'd be like i'm the hulk
i love that yeah just playing in mud
like getting dirty rough housing like my
her favorite color you're the youngest
yeah there's two of us my sister is
almost two years older than me youngest
dude yeah so like yeah her favorite
cousins were girls my favorite cousin
was a boy like we so i'm like rough
housing with my guy cuz you put barbies
in the microwave i don't know if i did
that but i pulled their heads off yeah
yeah yeah yeah they definitely
decapitated cut their hair like
to the worst like you know they were in
the freeman prep and i was like i don't
like this the reason they don't give
them genitals is they know we would just
be putting them all
they know 100 we'd be mutilating
it's like did you just perform a female
circumcision on malibu barbie
give me that outburst i'll put it back
and when i'm done snorting that elmer's
off i'm gonna be a surgeon leave me
alone
so
i just was like one of the things that i
wanted to focus on that was one of my
because when you do combo you should set
intentions like not just to like
not just to like be healthy which is
could be your only intention that's fine
like to get your body right but that's
so big that's very vague and tight
it is vague but what's a good intention
like i would like to release the grief
from my diet
absolutely very specifically yes and the
more specific your intentions are these
that's how these plant medicines work is
like
they they listen to you it's it's wild
like when you put your intentions into
like mushrooms before you do them you
will get that back like the mushrooms
when they're people call them magic
mushrooms and i didn't think anything
about that growing up like oh people
just called magic mushroom they
literally are magical so like so it
seems like that into them and they'll
give it back to you and also um
plants i'm just reading this off wiki so
just be
uh patient but plants may not be hearing
in the conversational sense as plants
lack brains and ears but plants do have
a vibration sensing receptors and so at
some level they can respond to sound i
mean they move towards light they move
towards light they're very smart they
they respond to your voice like i talk
to my plants um
and there's they they wait can we clip
that i talk to my plants
can we just close that
just
i talk to my plants
i'm such a nerd i wake up in the morning
and i'm like how are my plant babies
i put on my plant voice because i don't
have anything else to take care of well
no i like
like
yeah i mean this is just my
overdoing it because that's my thing i'm
a maximalist but like when i'm like
outside and i step on grass i'm like
sorry like i just the grass wants you to
step on it because it it's very
grounding do you know about grounding
yes yeah go outside step on the earth
man it's just it uh
it's we're all energy and electricity
and then we've got and and like magnets
so like when you we walk around in these
synthetic shoes which is not what we
were supposed to grab it's also we're on
pavement most of the time as well so
we're separated from so grounding also
called earthing is a therapeutic
technique that involves doing activities
that ground electr uh or electrically
reconnect you to the earth this practice
relies on earth earthing science and
grounding physics to explain how
electrical charges from the earth can
have positive effects on your body so
this um you know native americans when
um
you know they're
you know we're barefoot quite a lot and
when you're sick always be barefoot and
they also when you were sick they would
put you on a horse because horses are
more conductive oh i didn't know about
that yeah so it's like sit on a horse
and my my aunts when i was younger
whenever i was sick they would always
like sit me on a horse and i never knew
what was going on i'd be like i don't
want to do this everybody's like puking
off the side of a horse and they'd be
sitting me on a horse electrical
grounding is a process of removing
excess charge on an object by
transferring electrical charges from a
short circuit between uh
when a charged object has okay this is
the dorkiest fucking explanation
electricityform.com yeah that looks a
little bit silly to me um are you doing
um uh uh setting your butthole i don't
do that because i don't have my own if i
had your estate
i'd be sunning my butthole and my yoni's
hunting yeah yeah yeah or perineum i
always call i don't know what's the
correct way to where you uh throw your
uh you put your feet behind your head
and so that because your butthole has
the thinnest skin
get all that vitamin d that vitamin d i
mean
it's she's like i've taken some other
vitamin d in this very practice perineum
setting say there's a long list of
health benefits the main one is okay
this is where i i draw i do draw the
line
yes i will eat a frog shit i will
whatever
in 30 seconds of sunlight on your
butthole you will receive more energy
than you would in an entire day being
outside with your clothes on
others say premium stunning can stop
qui
queefing q i don't want to stop nothing
stop
leaking from the body inviting piranha
or solar energy it's like yeah solar
energy this is said to result in a
number of things including improved
sleep and concentration and you know
what though don't get arrested doing
this because that will not help your
life no i feel like someone might be
trolling us with this yeah this feels
someone invented this for all like the
names i am on alexjones.net is that bad
but yeah grounding basically you're
standing barefoot in the dirt yeah and
uh uh
i decided to do that weekly yeah but um
where was that uh frog so yeah back to
the intention uh yeah so setting
intentions with the plant medicines is
very important very important so one of
my
intentions was to
embrace my
divine femininity which i've never i
feel like i've been
pushing her away my whole entire life
for some reason and i didn't know why
and i will tell you why one because that
i figured that out after i did my
psilocybin the first time but
i you know even being in comedy like is
a very masculine yeah you have to do
yourself to do
we're immersed we're surrounded by
masculinity and i mean just in the world
but especially in comedy because it's a
male dominated and you have to command
an audience is very like fine well and
you also have to be very masculine so
that guys don't just go like i want to
fuck her and so the girls don't go she's
trying to steal my man they have to
neuter yourself
frank buddy oh see frank always
gravitates to the person that is the
being the most alpha so you're giving
off some big alpha yeah animals are
always going to gravitate to whoever has
the most alpha energy
is that what it is
yeah you're like clear and you're saying
like you're in charge hi but oh but i've
given him food in the past so he's going
to come to me too sorry to come back
sorry my dog is uh falling in love with
candace because of how clear and full of
source she is well that's another it's
true that is it's a thing animals have
been coming to me especially like
definitely more so you turn into a
fucking disney princess after you do
ayahuasca birds just start landing on
your shoulders it's like because one
yeah
like you get it you know we're made of
the same molecules we are all one 100
um i'm a i'm a cat person now after
doing combo and
mushrooms because
michelle the medicine woman she had
she's like you always has like animals
she's got animals that are hers and then
she'll foster animals too that just
comes they're animals we're designed to
be surrounded by animals
i mean there i mean the the i'll we
should put the studies in the foot note
of like people sleep better when they
hear animals breathing next to them
because that means you're protected yeah
it just makes sense and so
um so yeah so i was always just a dog
person i've always liked loved animals
but i for some reason was just like i
just don't have anything in common with
cats and i just never never gravitated
towards them but she had these two cats
that were there during
the
the experiences of a combo and with the
mushrooms one of them knew exactly
whenever the medicine's being applied
like just intuitively would come out
whenever michelle is applying the frog
medicine and just knew to be there when
these people are purging to hold space
to hold solid like
you can trust me space and that's but
that and that's why i'm just like i
became a cat person through this i
became a cat person in september when
all this went down this just happened in
september did you get one i'm in the
midst i'm gonna go to a shelter next
week with my friend who she's going to
take me to the place where she got her
cat so yeah so it's going to happen in
the very near future i'm so excited what
you name it
i've already been kind of juggling
because i am such a dork with nutrition
and health but i kind of like rishi and
chaga which are adaptogenic mushrooms
yeah so i'm debating but i don't know
i'll know but then you'll meet at the
capitol and then i'll be like hey
charles yeah exactly yeah
what's up rodney yeah no it's gonna get
a human name 100 probably because i've
always found that very interesting
yeah yeah i'm obsessed with naming dogs
like kevin or lisa kevin's my favorite
favorite
yeah
just like brad yeah random human names i
love it like naming a horse brandon is
so funny to me hilarious because
brandon's also high yeah
100 like you should it has to be a
second name
chad is just so funny to me
[Music]
we are now taking a break from our guest
so i don't know if you guys notice i'm a
little bit like
prickly
right i'm a little um
what's the word intolerant when y'all
come at me and like on instagram and
negative comments and stuff because
us in comedy we are giving i am giving
up my ability to have biological
children to try to make strangers laugh
that's why i love modern fertility
because i'm not a rich celebrity but i
still wanted but you work for one
i just want to know if i have any
thank you so much
sorry she's thank god for so much to
thank you that was in the podcast
did you get that just
but i still want to be able to know if
i'm fertile it just takes the pressure
off and worrying about whether you're
fertile or not makes cortisol and
adrenaline and that is what you know how
when you know so many uh women who we
can't get pregnant we're trying and
we're trying and the second they give up
and they're like we just had a glass of
wine and started looking to adoption
that's the night they get pregnant
because your body
is shutting down so that's why modern
fertility was created it's an easy and
affordable way to get emily off my back
it's an easy and affordable way to test
your fertility hormones at home with a
simple finger prick mail it in with your
pp mail it in with your prepaid label
don't panic it's not made by elizabeth
holmes it works and you'll get your
personalized results within 10 days
traditional testing with your doctor can
cost over a thousand dollars but modern
fertility gets you the same information
at 159 a fraction of the price and if
you go to modernfertility.com whitney
you can get 20 off your test that's 20
more towards your future child's college
education this is not a test you can
fail by the way don't panic right you
win either way right now modern
fertility is offering our listeners 20
off the test when you go to modern
fertility.com whitney that means your
test will cost 139 instead of the
several hundred or even a thousand plus
dollars it could cost at a doctor's
office get 20 off your fertility desk
and you go to modernfertility.com
whitney modernfertility.com whitney so
our next partner has i use athletic
greens every day it i have a picture
that i took downstairs that's in a i
order you know these these things um
from flea markets and i have a uh down
by my coffee you saw janice i've got a
thing of athletic greens that's in a i
put mine in a glass thing and every
morning just scoop it in
and i can't stop having energy like i
can't put myself with one delicious
scoop of athletic greens you're
absorbing 75 high quality vitamins
minerals whole foods source superfoods
probiotics and adaptogens it supports
mental clarity and alertness and your
subscription comes with a year's supply
of vitamin d
my year supply vitamin d is right here
right here i give her the sun baby i'm
the shine
oh my dick
vitamin d right here emily as soon as i
leave the room she's fucking yeah sure
she'll always satisfy yeah i didn't you
know what i didn't even i didn't get it
because i didn't expect it to come from
such a chaste mouth but
you you didn't expect it to come from
someone's nerve come before it vitamin d
is so important to add in these
lipsticks i give it to her every night
when we don't get as much sunlight and
it's cheaper than getting all of the
supplements yourself right now it's time
to reclaim your health and arm your
immune system with convenient daily
nutrition especially heading into the
flu and cold season it's just one scoop
and a cup of water every day you can
cook that's it no need for a million
different pills and supplements to look
out for your health to make it easy
athletic greens is giving giving you a
free one-year supply of immune
supporting vitamin d and five free
travel packs with your first purchase
all you have to do is visit
athleticgreens.com
whitney or visit the real vitamin d for
that for that vaccine okay
that's athletic greens.com whitney to
take ownership over your health and pick
up the ultimate daily nutritional
insurance
back to our guests why don't you get
frogs you know well come i do like i do
like i'm i do like certain like
reptilian and amphibian i don't like all
of them yeah i don't like dislike them i
just don't like for lizards i don't i'm
not a lizard person or a snake person
um but in amphibian i do like especially
now because combo was so life-changing
for me um
so yeah i could definitely get a frog
but i want to get a cat first and i feel
like the cat might try to eat the frog i
don't know if that's
something i'm putting on the cat i don't
know but um we'll see but a cat first
for sure i definitely need uh something
to take care of at this point yeah i was
i was about to show you but i think it
was just in her stories so it got
deleted but shannie darden um this
skincare specialist in l.a she's got
it's not a bearded dragon or something
and it's
it's wildly um
human yet dinosaur-esque
and
i just um posted on instagram a video of
me i just started to understand birds
birds before i didn't get same but they
i'm going to show you a video that's
going to blow your mind i have a new
respect for birds yeah me too they're
they have a wisdom will never understand
emily we've gone through crows can
recognize faces oh you know crows are oh
yeah they're using tools they if you
feed them they bring you gifts like yeah
we underestimated birds yeah that's
actually how i found your place i saw
vultures swarming above because then it
was like rotting flesh under my mind
they were coming from my head
they were coming from my uterus
i was preenium sunning and they
they smelled the rotting flesh
[Music]
okay i'm not gonna uh
because i know you have to go at some
point and i'm not gonna disrespect your
time but we're gonna do a round two and
so frog ceremony yeah okay
so so yes
i that my intention was tap into my
divine feminine even these the points on
my
inner right ankle where she administered
the combo is in the sign of the yen
to tap into my feminine and uh
i will definitely say that after i did
it three times
and then i did the psilocybin right
after that same night i did the third
combo so i did the third combo and the
psilocybin all in the same day
and that evening
an evil spirit of a woman left my body
when i was doing the psilocybin and in
that i knew that
in that interaction while she was
leaving my body
i was bawling again i was crying and it
was that same cry that i had when i
first did combo which i didn't know
where it was coming from but now here we
are at the end of the end of the month
where i'm doing the mushrooms and i'm
like oh this is why i was crying like
whatever when i did combo the first time
it shook this whatever this was inside
of me this evil
and i knew she was a woman i knew she
was uh some type of maternal
relationship to me whether it be
sure it was mitzi shore
from the comedy store
she she she was never gonna pass me and
so i had to pass her out of my body
so and
so yeah so i knew it was a maternal this
and this just is intuitive like i wasn't
having a conversation with this person
and i wasn't like
in that moment having like remembering
dialogue that i had with this person
this may not have even been someone i
had a relationship in a past life this
could have been like a great great
grandmother who had this type of
relationship with
you know my grandmother you know what
i'm saying and now i'm carrying that
with me just because it's in my dna so
there's something called family
constellation work which is goes deeply
into this epigenetic imprinting
just the science of this because it
probably sounds a little bit like
ghost
sciencey
you know so epigenetic imprinting is
essentially that um
when you are pregnant with a child the
chemicals that you uh
secrete in your brain the internal
medicine cabinet the child becomes
addicted to the same way a baby would be
addicted to crack if you were doing
crack they're pregnant if you're
emitting cortisol adrenaline
norepinephrine phenylethylamine when
you're pregnant those babies are going
to be addicted to whatever that is so if
your mom is in a bad marriage and
stressed out while she's pregnant you're
going to be born addicted to stress and
subconsciously seek out chaos and drama
throughout your life because that's my
drug is adrenaline like i've just
and the number one way to know if
someone's addicted to
adrenaline uh or
cortisol
their main phrase is i hate drama i just
hate drama someone says they hate drama
i love driving
so that's how to spot one um but so uh
these incredible studies which i know i
brought up on the podcast before but i
think deserves to be repeated which is
that you know when um a baby sees a
picture of a spider the baby recoils
even though it doesn't know what a
spider is right it's an inherited fear
so we've evolved to inherit fears from
our ancestors
look kind of creepy so they're not going
to be scared of a bunny rabbit exactly
but yeah but they've inherited that fear
so if someone's really afraid of heights
and someone's then someone's not it's
like oh one of your ancestors probably
fell off a cliff you know it's like you
can sort of tell it's like and you have
no idea where it came from and the more
sunken in your eyes are probably the
more your ancestors got punched in the
face and had to have their eyes evolved
to be sunken in more you know so it's
like there's there's a lot you can tell
about your ancestors based on the what
we call irrational fears that you have
yeah so anxiety disorders i have a lot
of anxiety it was yeah your ancestors
were probably like
things didn't go so well for them you
know
and to over pathologize yourself for
having anxiety or being afraid of
heights or being afraid of water or like
i'm terrified of water like something
happened to when your ancestors in the
water was bad i'm terrified of sharks
even though statistically you're more
likely to be killed by your television
set falling on your head than a shark
like we can tell a lot about what
happened
in your past there's an amazing study
about how mice um not that i love animal
testing but uh uh mice
when a mouse was electrocuted every time
it smelled a cherry blossom its
offspring smelled a cherry blossom and
ran to the other side of the cage
without being shocked so it inherited
that pavlovian fear and
already so we we do carry that you know
and then family constellation is to like
map back what happened to your ancestors
so you can figure out what you're
carrying guilt shame from your past and
fear so you go okay what's mine what's
my great aunts and what's my
grandfather's and what's my you know
this and that and uh real quick because
i'd interrupted before with this uh when
i was saying my therapist it's a witch
you know she's like very
neuroscience based emdr if you're going
to a therapist that doesn't recommend
things like 12-step programs and emdr
and other ways of healing besides just
talk therapy
that's a red flag another therapist yeah
because there's lots of free tools and
other kind of many ways yes and my
therapist
was like the goal is that you're not you
don't come to me forever if you come to
me forever i failed yeah like my goal is
to give you tools so that you can like
do this without me because there's other
people that need help and i can't just
listen to you talk about your fake
problems all day um and so she's like
the only problems you have are the ones
in your head like she's just like none
of these this is all old like i this is
done like just release it um
yeah she'll be like this problem is
boring like i can't even do this like
there's people there's people that need
real help and but there was one point
where she doesn't she doesn't want to
bring her like witchcraft into the the
therapy office but one time i was like
dealing with a toxic woman in the
hollywood business
who was you don't say who was haunting
me whose approval i needed but who
didn't like me and who was kind of
bullying me
and i was just the obsession of this and
um
you know we talk about all the toxic men
in comedy we don't talk about the women
i've been trying to talk about the toxic
women in comedy for years
ago
let's go of the people in this industry
that have been the meanest to me
it has been women
women
and i'm thinking about like of the
people that helped me it's definitely
been more men that have helped me well
that's a big thing and that's like look
the older women i'm like okay we have to
give a pass because they were
had the scarcity complex like for sure
of and
were
like a numbers thing as well like
there's definitely more men than women
i'm just gonna bow down to the women
that were like the executive producers
and the the casting directors and the
directors and stuff that were the only
woman in a male dominated field who
basically it what i mean when i started
comedy it was me versus you
there was one girl going down the line
up and it was me or you no i know yeah
like you know what i'm saying we were
competitors right like we were foes like
that's how the system was designed
against one another
there weren't spots yeah and they called
those queen b syndrome it's like the
woman has to be meaner to the new woman
coming in because also you don't want
the men to think that you're uh playing
favors right and that you're giving her
special treatment you have to be overly
mean to her just to show the men i'm not
being nice to her just because she's a
woman right you know i'm not soft so
it's like it's always internalized dumb
it's just so ridiculous um because i
think the bottom line is just as a
business person if you have more women
and uh diversity at your job you make
everyone makes more money it just makes
the business better product yeah it's
just a better product whatever you're
doing out of selfishness yeah be
i just did this corporate event because
emily was there where it was like i'm
seeing a lot of white guys here like if
you hire diverse and women you make more
money so if you're a good greedy person
you should be hiring more moms
moms don't have to do ten things at once
yeah i think a lot of it is just
laziness i and fear of getting sued or
whatever for sure um
but yeah no it's it's it's wild like i
remember i was doing a festival
and
someone and i
the
i was at this festival
and there was a person there a woman
there who was booking another festival
who came to
a producer of this festival and said hey
i'm booking this festival
what women of color would you recommend
and she was like candace thompson is
amazing she just killed it on this show
i watched her last night put book her on
your on your in your festival and she
says to me oh no i'm sorry not to me but
to this woman who then tells me she said
well she's not dark enough to put on the
flyer
oh no i mean you you know what i'm
talking about but i tried to cast a
a black person uh in a tv show once and
i was told they were too urban
and like you know i like that i mean
that was 10 years ago that wasn't that
long ago no you know what i mean right
right so but um just to finish that
we'll close the the hatch on uh my
therapist i'm dealing with this i was
like oh maybe it's my mom and i'm
projecting on to this girl who's bullied
me in comedy and maybe it's my drama for
my family and my ancestral and she goes
just write her name down on a piece of
paper and put it in the freezer
it's the witch i was like what
so that's like some witchcraft shit is
if you have like an enemy or uh nemesis
or something you write their name down
and put it in a freezer and put it in
the freezer
i don't know what that means but i was
like uh
bitch do i pay for this session do i
call the police like i have a yelp
review on the way i will get like uh
okay and i did it and i
did it work i think so
it's i'm telling you like this world is
magical and people don't like to they
they're
magic is a charged word like yeah it
just sounds like you know it's the same
thing with psychics it's like it's like
and i wrote about this my book is like i
don't believe in psychics i believed in
this the one psychic i went to i think
psychics basically just show you like
you already know everything and the good
psychics just hold up a mirror so if
right answers are all within you yeah
they just hold up a mirror to you the
way you say something
like the person you already know
everything you know yeah everyone just
needs to learn and through whatever
process or means it takes is to learn
how to trust themselves because we have
things to not eat go to not eat
oh god uh just gun to your head around
in america dairy if you're going to do
dairy do raw dairy go find a farm even a
health food store that's got raw milk
raw cheese raw butter breast yes goat
milk no milk you don't even want to know
what i've been doing right now i do i
need to put out that i came up with the
invention of having a breast milk
factory years ago women
milk bank milk
pumping breast milk and selling it
why do we think it sounds gross to us
because we're like someone's but it
doesn't at all
i think i think babies i think that yeah
eating other animals breast milk has
always been odd to me yeah no it is a
little it is we're the only species that
doesn't especially with all the the
hormones and shit they put in for sure
but like yeah no so i've not been
dabbling in breast milk but what do you
what kind of milk is zebra milk it's not
super milk it's not milk nut semen it's
not milk it's not semen oh no pus zit
pot no
okay
i'm weird okay there is a line i may or
may not so every time like it comes out
and i see people getting mad at
something that like conspiracy theorists
are talking about i'm like i'm gonna try
this i'm gonna look into it and see
what's going on
so are you on duckduckgo we doing
duckduckgo i i've been i mean i've used
that search engine before i i have used
duckduckgo yes of course because google
trucks
no not duck milk it's not milk okay
it's not milk milk is canceled but
recently it was in the mainstream media
that somebody was some naturopathic
healer was talking about drinking
something that was disgusting
according to mainstream you know and
just americans
standards
i tried my own pee oh
i tried i tried you're in therapy
you're in therapy yeah i am you're in i
am there you are in therapy you can do
your own
you're in therapy yeah no my friend
davina
has been doing the one i mentioned
earlier
with something
no
vodka nope no drinking before because
what color is your urine should it be a
certain color because mine is neon
yellow is that okay
yeah maybe you don't have a uti when you
do it it's supposed to glow in the dark
because mine mine is uranium
mine might be washer fluid actually how
do we feel how did it go well i'm i've
it's been a week now okay almost so i'm
doing it to fully do it great
thank you
emily's face i'm 65 years old
to make it even crazier
uh
so my friend davina who i i have to give
another shout out to because she's the
one that introduced me to michelle for
combo but also she's been doing posts
about urine therapy because
she follows people on instagram and then
i started following some people on
instagram and then there's this one guy
named nick caputo who was on this
podcast um i think it's called the best
you ever had i think is what the podcast
is called but anyway he's urine
everything like talks about the benefits
of it and how we are just been
conditioned to believe that this is
waste it's not waste it's literally just
your filtered blood
so and it's got stem cells in it it's
got
uh
homemade i've been peed on so maybe
that's why it looks so good and it's a
very intimate thing it does help it's
anti-aging 100 but but what is why is
that why do i want a clown on it is it
is it it's i'm conditioned to go
pee-pee's bad yeah it comes out of a
it's crazy yeah it it why am i not we
know how it's on board why am i not on
board
because here's the thing the eating the
placenta which is a big that's a huge
thing too
but i i'm not sold it's like it is all
the toxic waste from and grace will know
the answer to this but like it's the
toxic waste that
you're taking so that it doesn't get
into your baby and people like well well
wolves do what dogs do it they eat their
placenta
to uh basically uh so that predators
don't smell blood
that's why they they don't eat it for
the bite they don't eat it for the
vitamin b yeah i've not done too much
research into so when predators eat
their placenta after birth it's so that
there's not blood that kind of can pick
up on yeah so if you're in a hospital or
whatever and you have a placenta you
don't need to eat it there's no pred
there's no tigers around that's right
but okay so i fully had placenta this
morning
was that a smoothie no i know bitches
they're like i put my placenta in my
smoothie i'm like that's just all the
mercury and bull and extra iron and
chemicals that your body was trying to
clean out yeah well with uh it's a with
urine and again i just i'm studying this
now yes like so and i so i and i always
prefer everything it's hard for me to
not make jokes i'm trying to want you to
make jokes i know i'm trying to not i'm
trying to be respectful of this okay you
can make fun but also that's how we
normalize things too right
it's just we're talking about it so and
this is brand new to me so i don't know
what i'm doing and i say this about ever
before i say anything is i know nothing
yeah i just know what works for me so
yeah what works for me doesn't
necessarily work for you but because if
it stresses you out to drink your own
urine you're undoing the benefits so i
might still be there right and i and you
know i tried doing this years ago
because i'm such a health freak and i'm
like i'll try anything for like in the
name of health i'm that person yeah i
should probably have some travel show
where i just i was gonna say yeah yeah
and just go cause i'll do most anything
except eat like animal stuff cause i
don't want to hurt animals but yeah so
the urine i tried this years ago and
then i just didn't stick with it because
obviously i was young i was like in my
early 20s and just was like it's pee so
i'm not going to do it yeah and my pee
in my early 20s was like just blue
ribbon pap's blue ribbon
straight up fighters
mike's far lemonade
so this is what is and i have a friend
who also told me she got over her cat
allergies by drinking her pee for one
week just one week and she's not
allergic did she set an intention before
she drank the pee i don't know is
allergic to dogs so so here let me let
me run to the bathroom real quick
because she knows we need to let you go
oh yeah soon but i want to close the
door yeah yeah we're we're good we're
not i'll let you know if i need like to
flee okay um
so this is what
uh this person i follow on instagram
who's all about urine therapy
uh they posted this so this is what's in
it when you drink your urine
spu hormone which is an antibiotic
analgesic immune system booster
it's got growth hormone in it it's got
immunoglobulin which generates virus and
bacteria antibodies interferon which
boosts immune system inhibits cancer
cells gonadotropin which stimulates
hormone production urokinase which
dissolves blood clots
antineoplastin which helps to cure
cancer
prostaglandins which conditions the
blood arteries and veins urea which i
will say back in the day first of all
this is like an ancient therapy people
do this and not even in india and china
they've been doing this for
centuries but what else i will say they
do they like this is where my hater
brain goes yeah yeah they also kill
bears for their gallbladder for some
bullshit fake medicine they also kill
octopus because you know what i mean
they also are like killing pangolins for
their scales because they say you know
so it's like for sure and that's why you
just have to use your own discernment
but also i
am i have noticed already like health
benefits like
so and i just started doing this and it
sort of be like a week i think tomorrow
but energy levels
i'm more calm like i'm thinking more
clearly
i'm definitely more hydrated i um
i have people
complimenting me on my skin they're like
you're glowing and i'm like it's pee
but also i felt it the first place where
it starts to detox is like your gut and
your colon and i've always had like gut
issues and colon issues and so i felt it
working in there and like it it clear
cleared me out like i felt it and i feel
so much lighter like
and i'm just i more present like i'm can
i ask you a question energy is great
yeah you eat so clean i do someone
doesn't eat clean is there pee good for
them yes
still apparently so and again i'm not no
expert do not quote me but from what i
from the people that i started listening
to on these podcasts and started
following on instagram
you could have a not great diet but your
pee would still be healthy for you
who's and then my brain just goes yeah
uh hater brain goes like who's doing the
studies like and then we go what do they
stand to gain dr urine
i wonder why our bodies are so amazing
why would it get rid of all that good
stuff that's a great question i don't
know
that's something well maybe we were
intended to drink it i mean i've seen
dogs like their own pee and dogs eat
their own shit dude
other versus shit so when horses eat eat
other horses poop it usually means
they're lacking in some minerals for
sure and it's loaded with minerals rp so
and again yeah maybe it's there to so
that we have this never-ending well of
nutrients for us so that you could eat
your own shit if you were starving i
wouldn't recommend that okay until wait
till round two when she's like guys i
just started getting my own shit on this
new poop diet i'm on this new poop quick
this past week i'll do my first pee
which is supposed to be the best one
because at night your body just is so
regenerative and it works on all these
functions so
that one is going to be the most potent
also at night try it's hard to do if
you're an apartment try turning off all
your wi-fi
things at night yeah so any damage that
emfs could possibly be doing yes to your
body our bodies can regenerate but at
night like put everything in airplane
mode unplug your wireless printer your
micro like everything and just see what
happens to your health i got one of
those soma vedics which is like an emf
uh mitigator it's a device i just have
and so it helps to clear out that stuff
too which is by the way it's it's the
science isn't all there yet but i think
we can all agree that like we can
there's something shady about some uh
something going to space and back yes in
a sec a millisecond that we put next to
our uterus
yeah so it's like people like well
there's no data on it well because none
of them none of the cell phone company
like i mean there's
you know a
very prominent cell phone company has
put aside
uh like hundreds of millions of dollars
for future lawsuits from emf stuff
already i'm not going to say which one
um
and just because the data doesn't isn't
there does it mean it's a thing i mean
we also used to in shoe stores you would
x-ray your feet you would walk in i mean
the amount of x-rays we were oh uh
exposed supposed to i mean every time we
fly every yeah flying that's a nightmare
well because remember emily when we
were with me remember when i was working
on the emf suits for planes like putting
uh i was studying like which uh
materials can block emfs and i was
trying to work on a fabric that was um
excuse me uh that had copper laced in it
so it could stop emf so when you're
pregnant you could wear it and emf proof
emf proof paint for your baby room uh
emf proof uh
like hats fanny pack sports bras so if
you're running with your sports bra
you're not just getting your heart and
your tits pounded by emfs like just in
case like maybe they're benign that'd be
great for that to be the case but like
sort of as safely assessed yeah as like
women you're kind of like okay well all
these women died in the birth control
studies in puerto rico like we're lab
rats with this stuff like i hope it's
nothing but
but i would love to just have like on
this side of safety yeah exactly so yeah
it's just like i just don't want to
pound my baby with emf by accident by
flying all the time just like have an
option and um and then i went to a very
big sports uh company
are you with me i did it after wendy
williams in new york remember i went to
a very i went to a very big sports
company that does like you know leggings
and and tops and stuff and i was like uh
and they do ones with sunscreen in it
for athletes that are outside like
shirts with sunscreen yeah great idea
and i was like oh why don't we do emf
like can you do a line that's emf proof
you know because i would love to talk to
apple and att and all these people and
go hey
like
get ahead of this and just be like the
same way that right that william mor
william morris you should have some kind
of like you should be working on the
lung cancer technology well you know
what i'm saying like like just get ahead
of it just use your greed to just solve
the problem you created right so why
can't i go to one of the cell phone
companies and go hey why don't you guys
be the first on the ground floor of
doing studies on this so you can go
here's your cell phone and your emf
proof suit and your emf proof when
you're pregnant and your baby blanket
and all your stuff because none of us
right now if everyone said ems are
absolutely giving you cancer
like
cell phones are probably the cigarettes
of today absolutely what cigarettes were
50 years ago no one would stop using it
nobody so just get it on the ground
floor and just make the technology and
so i went to this huge company i was
after wendy williams and i was like in
my like little like
trina turk wrap dress or whatever that i
had to return in like two days and uh
and i sat down and i pitched them this
whole deck of here's the data we have
about emfs uh and
what's you know how this has changed
like i had all this data all this stuff
i had all these scientists like call in
and i was like so do you want to work on
the technology where we put copper
threaded in so that when you go on a
plane you can just put on your emf proof
everything when you go through the tsa
pre-check when you go through the x-ray
machine you got it on
and he goes this is a brilliant idea
this is a huge idea
but why do we need you
he goes why don't i just give you twenty
thousand dollars right now twenty
thousand it was like why don't i just
give you twenty grand like why do we
need you
and i was like that's a really good
point and i was like you know what fine
i'm sure other people have had an idea
like that i don't care can you just make
it available
so that i can have a kid like not
freaking out i can some people can
produce so i'm not like freaking out
about like you know i'm saying i was
like just can you please make it so i
don't know if they're working on it or
not and i was like please steal my idea
i don't care like i'm not qualified to
follow through with this like right i'm
just crazy do something i'm just crazy
enough to have had the idea right
can you but i do know it's worth more
than twenty thousand dollars yeah he's
like but he's gonna pay you off so
fucking like shakespearean succession
like the he was like the um what's his
name from uh succession who's like dad
oh logan
yeah it was very like he's like but why
do we need you
and i was like you don't
you don't and then the music plays yeah
yeah yeah exactly so we're doing a round
two because there's no we didn't even
get to conspiracy theories no i know we
all left with it and then but i was
going to close with just by saying like
and this is why i trust nothing because
of what you just you know how fucking
wild my algorithm is the shit i'm
getting marketed this morning after last
night watching videos on chemtrails and
mkultra
and we didn't even get to it's literally
like i'm literally getting like like um
ads for like rehabs and detox centers
my algorithm is so weird
wait until you start looking up p
therapy p therapy
i definitely will because there was an
episode of
my strange addiction where someone was
drinking their pee you know what i mean
and then like there was someone that
would eat baby powder
but the person that i want to go back
and look at the episode of my strange
addiction where this woman was only
drinking her pee and just see how she
looks see and that yeah but that's and
that's a thing where i would be like the
conspiracy my conspiracy brain is like
yeah of course they advertise that as
being not good for you they make it look
like it's this unhealthy addiction when
it's probably well they want you to go
buy the vitamin water and like no one's
and gatorade and whatever but imagine
telling everyone hey you have this thing
inside of you that's endless stream of
something inside of you it's hard really
it's a it's i it's hard it's like it's
mental it's hard to wrap my head around
gross it's bad same thing with that back
with our our menstruation but um i
remember me and my sister both remember
my grandmother saying that they would
take she would take a
baby diaper they had urine in it and
they would she would put on her face she
would take the diaper and then put the
urine on her on her face and if you look
at
face products that you lotion urea is
one of the ingredients it's pee it's in
there and
uh they would back in the day and they
still do this i can't even say back in
the day i believe they still do this
they collect
from like sewer systems like they take
urine pharmaceutical companies because
they take the stem cells and they use
that in medicine they would take from
porta-potties they would collect from
port-au-prince the pharmaceutical
companies know about the benefits but
they don't want us to know about what
i'm saying because then we wouldn't need
to
then we would need to go to them that's
crazy
your urea is in a bunch of stuff and
they they would collect it publicly
because they know the benefits of it so
yeah that's it but we would get them for
free and when we'd have we could cut out
the middleman
so i'm just saying
it's it's taboo to talk about and i know
i've exposed myself with some very
personal information today but um
coincidence that i have to go pee pee
right now no i think that's the universe
telling you it's time
i am like
you know this class is always in session
that's our deal here and like always
learning always asking questions like
nothing's too scary and like always
happy to be wrong
yeah and it by the way i always like to
say it's true for now until it's not so
also yeah in two years you might go you
know what that's not true anymore
because i'm drinking l.a tap water or
whatever and don't drink your pee
exactly and now we do this now it's like
i think it's just staying flexible
because i think there's this this
wellness exhaustion that happens it's
like oh when someone's like you
shouldn't be eating avocados you're
looking for awesome oh my god like i
just got into blueberries you know like
right and it's like i think it's just
staying flexible and staying teachable
and not getting over overwhelming and
exhausting yourself with it because if
you're stressing yourself out by this
stuff it it undoes the whole point right
you know every now and then just like
have a night where you just like eat a
burger and don't drink your pee and go
to bed at 2 a.m and get 4 hours like
everything in moderation yeah everything
in moderation and it's like everything
is different for everybody and
i just think that when there's many
things that we thought were crazy and
then in 10 years we were like now it's
just common oh it was crazy because you
didn't want us to know it like it is
very possible that in 50 years like in
order to get health insurance you have
to be drinking your own pay for them to
even consider so you consider it you
know what i mean like that is on the
table like it is possible that there's a
god if it there's it is possible that in
the future like if you're not taking
metformin you can't get health insurance
yeah like there's a lot of people that
like this is going to be a he's like i'm
on metaphor yeah like there's a lot of
stuff i mean yeah uh uh let's sin used
to be in soy milk like or you know like
you know all the stuff and there's also
yeah so
crazy yeah like we used to think bottled
water was healthy now we're like oh it's
got the phthalates in it and you can't
you know so it's just like there's a lot
of shit that seemed crazy back in the
day that
cigarettes you said vitamins in them
they used to prescribe cigarettes to
pregnant women yeah
okay going to let you get to your
because you're shooting a double podcast
uh i have nothing to say i don't know
what i'm going to be nosy neighbors um
not noisy neighbors i don't know why
that is such a weird projection i think
it's
everyone does it it's just it's your
it's an illiterate thing and it's a lazy
sloppy like just reading really quickly
yeah and then i did not bring up um all
the vitamins uh that i'm taking that are
right here holding up
the table vitamins mmn dmae ester c
uh b12 uh folate b12 some of us can't
digest b12 so you have to figure out if
you have the gene that makes you not be
able to digest it you need foliated b12
cod liver oil d3 uh nad um resveratrol
we were going to talk about that but
we'll do it next time don't write
elephants candace thompson
wild
thanks whitney i'm obsessed with you
we're friends now
[Music]
[Applause]